so Emirates day one had to finger me
sort of avoid finding anything that you
shouldn't have because it's sort of
under the sheets like that and she said
little bit worried about her weight that
way I'm well I know I know it so I asked
makeup Titan if they had a sponge and so
I put Spanish there the fungus sponge it
was a big wet Spanish picture just going
up my leg and shoe it Olivia just where
do you stand on the whole kit off thing
I rather not yes that's a totally
respectable choice in fact it might even
be respectable was the audition where
you went you had to dress all sexy oh
yeah I mean it was very early on so
maybe my third or fourth ever audition
and I was going to see a really
well-known well-respected theatre
casting director and I was so excited
and I had this script sent through and
the character was quite a raunchy hooker
so I bought some fishnets and I had a
top as low as I dared and the short
skirt and I wore a big duffle on the way
there when I got there I took off what
did you think about the character of
Matilda or something and I was thinking
don't think that was the character I was
looking at that sort of half an hour
sort of trying to pretend that I knew
what she was talking about and then she
realized I haven't got the same script
that she had and passed over the real
script which is about nuns
[Applause]
there was a slight road rage incident
and you know those crossings whether
absolutely I don't know if it's the same
rules apply but they're not staggered
they're straight cross road thing no
idea what you're talking about
right you have to turn in front of each
other not behind each other on a
staggered crossing no and you've got to
go behind it yes okay so this one was
coming towards me and wanted to go right
her right and I was going right so I I
turned to go in front of her and she and
as if I had tried to drive into her and
I thought okay well there's no one else
coming in so just to keep her happy I'll
do what's wrong but I'll go behind her
and she was doing in the car
and it was started to really piss me off
cuz I was right and now is helping her
out and then I suddenly got this red
mist just as our cars were coming next
to each other I said just as she was
doing that red
[Laughter]
every the 14 Valentine's Day Olivia :
what will you be doing on Valentine's
Day oh I'll be watching film your film
comes out oh my god hi pulling teeth
okay wait cuz I thought you meant cuz
it's a perm years before that so I'm
actually watching on that day I thought
you meant what would I be doing and I
was thinking I'll be sitting with
millions of others in a cinema watching
my new film Cuban fury this is a human
fury a new British comedy with yourself
a Nick Frost could be you with a leg in
the air now I can safely say later
without fear of contradiction it is the
best British based salsa rom-com no it's
a really funny sweetville is it lovely
film now who are you and I can't let you
remember the name of my character
[Laughter]
laughs sex law is promoting absolutely
didn't know who she was playing in the
film it was finished it was in the
cinema it was a long time after we'd
before you came on a chat show
[Music]
I have no idea why this the also cause
contractually no offense but we sort of
asked to come and
[Applause]
doesn't one day to be here there
great but I do wonder why they asked me
to do it
thinking she's never been one of my
phone
she's good and now how much preparation
goes into well obviously put a nose on
but what else goes on preparing for
cowcatcher I should make up some but
when you're playing it at something like
a detective do you do like for
broadchurch did you do preparation David
did and I could ask him questions it
seems silly doubling up to defend my
actions I think my character spoken the
same sort of rhythms as detectives so I
thought it'd be better if I didn't have
that influence
well Nick Frost is the lead guy and he
as a child I'm his sister and as
children
he was South's a champion and endless
cups and awards and things and we used
to go off and do competitions and as his
dance partner and then something
happened and his life changed and Sauza
wasn't for him after that moment and
then cut to Nick Frost present day or
whatever his characters called and he's
called Bruce
[Applause]
the names of people you film something
yes
Nelson Mandela we know you're not into
big do you not it makes preparation but
you must have had some down - yes - I
was forced to because I had to dance on
screen so I had to practice do you look
good though
well there is as you know they have
people who actually can dance yeah who
cuz I can only spin three times before I
vomit so we do we do have a picture of
you in rehearsals where it doesn't look
like it's going that well
ever
like a full sweat suit and heels it's
just amazing it's wonderful you know
that that you know you're very
successful in this country and much
beloved but now you see kind of the
world discovering you and but like but
now you see you in things like Vogue and
all these things doing high fashion
shoots and stuff like is this what you
dreamt of this very high at last no I
love my job very much I love it I love
going to work which is I know very lucky
yeah yeah but the other stuff is a bit
bad what do you have to do it do you
have to kind of rock up you have to do
it I think I've been sort of persuaded
to do it I definitely know do you know
if you have to do it yeah
we don't have to do it but do they say
but they person oh you have to yeah cuz
like I don't know that I do but then
suddenly find yourself it's important
tries it yeah they say that yeah they do
you say that a lot I said you had to do
this right yeah even I've been told I
have to do this
this is genuinely one of the things
that's really enjoyable to do
[Applause]
[Music]